that's a disgrace it's a disgrace and
you know the world watches that
they're all democrat run cities and
states
new york chicago
unfortunately pennsylvania and many of
them are closed right because you know
why they're closed because they thought
it would hurt our numbers and then they
saw
33.1 that was a big number
the anti-american radicals defaming our
noble history heritage and heroes they
support
joe biden antifa and the rioters and
looters and marxists
and left-wing extremists they all
support
sleepy joe biden sleepy joe
and by the way just so you understand
because look joe
joe is has no clue okay
joe's just not he's not calling the
shouts and i guarantee he won't be
calling him for very long
this election comes down to a simple
choice
do you want to be ruled by the corrupt
selfless political class or do you want
to be ruled and governed by
the american people which is what we're
doing which is one of the reasons
a vote for biden is a vote to give
control of government
over to the globalist communists
want to silence censor cancel and punish
you
if you want your children to be safe if
you want your values to be respected if
you want to be treated
with honor dignity and respect then i am
asking you to go tomorrow and vote
for trump
well it's up to you really you got to
get out i'm telling you again i'll say
it again and again
pennsylvania i've done very well you've
had your best years ever
pennsylvania it's going to be up to you
such a big deal
big state everything and we're doing
great in florida you know florida's been
great
you notice they're not talking about
florida anymore florida's been great
we're doing great in florida so we get
florida we get pennsylvania
we're going to get north carolina we're
doing great in north carolina you saw
the poll come out yesterday in iowa way
ahead in iowa
we're way ahead in ohio except we get
fake sometimes a fake poll we're way
ahead
we won ohio by eight points they say
we're further up than that this time
because we have everything i talked
about we have done
and more we've done more than i talked
about remember what i said four years
ago
i am your voice and we will make
america great again that's what we're
doing
[Applause]
for the last four years the depraved
swamp has tried
everything to stop me because they know
that i don't answer to them
i answer to you and it's true we did
this together
you know this is a movement the likes of
which this country
in a way the world probably but this
country has never seen
you know this country's never seen you
take some of the things that have
happened over
many many years a politician runs
and comes in second in new hampshire
becomes famous for the rest of his life
we won well we won everything this time
we won 100
of the states in the primaries right but
we won 34 states against
a crooked person right a very crooked
person
how crooked is by the way how crooked is
hillary she deleted 33 000 emails
what's happening with us but we won
we won we won like nobody's ever right
nobody's ever won like we've won no no
the likes of which nobody's ever seen
anything like it and and just to get off
that subject for a second
we had 2016. we had a campaign
nobody's ever seen anything like it can
i be honest there is
much more enthusiasm for this campaign
than there was four years ago
because four years ago i came and i was
a successful guy and i said we're going
to do this
we're going to cut your taxes we're
going to get rid of regulations
we're going to rebuild your military
wiggle this and that and that that
and i did everything and more than
everything
we're going to take care of our vets we
just got a 91
approval rating on the from the vets on
the va
okay no but think of it we did
everything we said we were going to do
but there is much more and you know what
that was a record there was never a
campaign nobody's ever seen a campaign
like that
that and brexit look at him look at him
we have nigel
i spotted nigel oh nigel
but i actually did see a list nigel they
said the victory of president trump was
number one
brexit was number two but it was a
distant number two and
and even nigel agrees with that no
nigel's been fantastic what a what a
voice he's
great voice great guy thank you thank
you it's an honor to have you
it's an honor
they know nigel brexit mr brexit
but uh the level of enthusiasm and i
think you're going to see a great
red wave tomorrow
[Applause]
and i think it's going to blow them away
and we get florida and we get
pennsylvania and
we're going to get we're going to get
new hampshire we're going to get new
hampshire
yeah they say get new york can you
believe that
see the the disadvantage the
disadvantage we have
the disadvantage we have because i think
in certain ways you
campaign totally differently the
disadvantage we have with the electoral
college you automatically lose
automatically i don't care if you bring
back abraham lincoln
and george washington as his running
mate you lose
new york illinois and california okay
so now you're you got three of the
biggest
and the biggest but you have three
monster states
that's an automatic loss so you're
starting off so then you have to run
and so we ran florida then we got
georgia by the way we're doing very well
georgia we got georgia we got north
carolina
we got pennsylvania that was a very
important deal we got pennsylvania we
got everything
then we got wisconsin and michigan we
said whoa
remember they wouldn't give you the
credit we were two points short we're at
98 percent of the vote tabulated
98 and it stayed there for hours and if
i lost
every single vote right every and i
still win so i said why aren't they
calling
pennsylvania they wouldn't do you the
honor and then they called
wisconsin great state and they called
michigan which hadn't been won in
years and years and they took the
glamour so will you please
give yourself the glamour this time give
yourself the glory okay
and make sure your governor doesn't
cheat okay if you're good
because they're known for very bad
things very very bad things here
can you imagine the pollster saying you
have to allow five percent
in pennsylvania for cheating that's a
terrible thing to say
of course everybody knows it's true now
but we have a lot of eyes watching they
never had eyes watching we got a lot of
very powerful eyes watching them
they don't want that to happen to
themselves together we will defeat the
corrupt establishment and we'll dethrone
the failed political class
we will drain the washington swamp and
we will save
the american dream we're going to save
the american dream
this election is also a choice between a
deadly
biden lockdown or a safe vaccine that
ends the pandemic
and we build the greatest economic
country that we've ever had there'll be
nothing like it we will
mass distribute the vaccine you know
we've done such a great job with this
whole thing you look at europe they're
spiking it's everybody you know they say
look at the way germany's doing look at
the way
france is doing look at spain
look at now italy right you know italy
in a really rough path that it went
well they're all they're all uh having a
lot of problems you know i said what
they don't use those examples anymore
but we have better numbers than all of
them you look at our numbers they're
better and it's bigger and it's
and you don't get and you don't get a
lot of you know a lot of the numbers you
don't get because
believe it or not there are some
countries that don't give you an honest
kick right you know that right
it will quickly eradicate the vaccine
will quickly eradicate the virus
and wipe out the china plague once and
for all and let me tell you we're
rounding the corner anyway
but we have the vaccines coming very
shortly they didn't want to give me the
credit they were saying no don't oh they
fought me like crazy did you see that
they didn't want it to happen before the
election but everybody knows
so we have the vaccines going to be very
quickly delivered by our military our
military is ready to go logistically
joe biden is promising to delay the
vaccine
and turn america into a prison state
locking you in your home
but you're already locked in your home
so
i hope that doesn't take away any of
your incentive
you're already locked in your home
while letting far-left rioters roam free
isn't that something right
you can't go to church you can't take
your family to dinner
but you can let people riot down the
middle of your
beautiful shopping street knocking the
hell out of people
burning down your stores like in
minneapolis
burning the hell out of the place until
we sent in the national guard
that ended in 31 minutes it was amazing
when they started getting whacked with
tears they were i hope they weren't
aiming did you see ali velcher
he went down ali i don't even know who
the hell he is i just know he
he does a very nice job of shaving his
head
this is ollie belcher and this is a
friendly protest and behind him the
entire city is burning it's like
berlin on its worst day right this is a
friend you know they don't report
you know if you have a badge like in a
democrat-run city they don't report it
nobody even i don't watch cnn actually
so i i don't know about it
but i did see the clips and then the ali
voucher then get hit
on the knee with tear gas from our
from our great national guard no he got
hit he went down
i'm down i'm down oh what a group of
people
cnn how dishonest is cnn
but you know what i think nbc is more
dishonest than cnn
i think nbc and abc
i think abc is terrible i mean abc is
absolutely
how about how about where they interview
me and every question is a kill they're
going for the kill
and then they interview sleepy joe and
it's like oh
the most boring interviews they don't
ask him anything
they don't ask him whether or not he's
corrupt are you corrupt hey sleepy joe
are you corrupt
remember i asked him that question and
chris wallace of fox
wouldn't allow it i said why why why
well i don't think it's appropriate to
ask right now chris wallace he is not
mike he will never be mike
he tries hard but he will not be mike
you know why he doesn't have the talent
the biden lockdown will mean no school
no graduations no weddings
no easter no thanksgiving no christmas
no fourth of july
and basically no future for american
youth other than that actually it's
quite a wonderful thing
a vote for biden is a vote for lockdowns
layoffs and misery you're going to have
a miserable time
you know what the the fake news doesn't
know
they're getting the highest ratings in
the history of television
when trump is gone they're all going
bankrupt
they will go down they're going to say
oh i wish you they're going to be
calling
we want trump to run again we want him
to run again
the fake news the new york times are
failing new york times
we'll be out of business now now can you
imagine you have four more years
true though right
can you imagine can you imagine these
people
they're getting the highest ratings on
television they've taken over for the
nfl people don't like how about
basketball
how about lebron i felt badly for lebron
i felt very badly
down 71 percent the cha and that's for
the champion i didn't watch one i didn't
watch one shot i get bored back four
back you know why when they don't
respect our country when they don't
respect our flag
nobody wants to watch nobody
and the nfl is way down that the nfl is
way down
you got to stand for our flag you got to
really be great to our flag and to our
anthem
and if you don't do that without
watching
what a crowd
what a crowd
hey i have three more of these to do do
you want me to stay with you all day yes
so yesterday i did five i actually did
six because i did
one early for some people but i actually
did six but i did five i got home at two
o'clock in the morning
in miami i got home two o'clock in the
morning
and i said good what time do we start
tomorrow uh eight o'clock sir i said
great let's go
but you know what it is i'm doing a run
a great great marathon everyone even the
one thing i'll say
they say i can't believe you know
because sleepy joe will go out he'll
talk for 10 minutes he's very agitated
you know
he's so angry okay he's got the he's got
the shades on now they should be a
little bit larger
the aviators right are they called
aviators he's got the aviators on and
he's so angry he's just
and he's reading every word he never
goes off teleprompter
because he gets lost if he can't go off
he gets lost no but the anger but it's
not really anger it's agitation you know
what that means man
that's what happens is when you lose it
you get very he's
can happen to all of us someday but he
can't you can't let it happen to your
president i'm sorry
but he was so angry he was so agitated
this morning
the glasses were pouring off everything
kept on oh there's nobody around him
the closest person is about 60 feet away
a reporter that can't believe he got
this good location inner circle that's
supposed to be for
vips right
now he's got lady gaga lady gaga
is not too good i could tell you plenty
of stories i could tell you stories
about lady gaga i know a lot of stories
lady gaga and john bon jovi every time i
see him he kisses my ass
oh mr president
but he'll get he'll get something out of
it just like everyone is but
you know what happens you bring in some
of these they don't by the way we drove
much bigger crowds than
these people but you know what happens
he'll sing a song or two and then he'll
leave and the crowd will leave and
sleepy joe's up there talking that
happened to hillary clinton
they got beyonce and they got
jay-z right jay-z and he started using
the f-word do you remember in front of
this graph
and it was unbelievable he was using the
f word f word f word
and the crowd is gone and then they left
and the crowd left and hillary was
standing on stage with an empty place
and she was talking
and she lost and people with support let
me tell you something when you look at
these crowds that we're getting
there's never been anything like it this
is just not the crowds this is your
ultimate poll
this is not the crowds of a second place
finisher
you know they said yesterday they said
well you know some people are here since
nigel they're here from
uh 24 hours 48. we have guys we have
people in line for three four days
and then the the press says but will
they vote well wait a minute they're
willing to go
they're willing to wait four days three
days two days one day online
will they vote will they stand there for
an hour and vote i think they're going
to vote you've got to over who is going
to vote
[Applause]
okay and seriously is there anybody here
who's going to vote for sleepy joe
no is there anybody that would have the
courage to put up their hands
no ah but he was born in screen what a
phony he is
he was born in scratch i'm a scranton
boy
did you see i'm tired of the smart
people did you see where he said yes
i'm tired of the smart people but we
want a smart
person as president you gotta have a
slug no he said
he made a lot of bad moves yesterday
didn't he was having a bad day yesterday
he's tired of smart people uh i can't
get too tired of him
to me that's an amazing statement if you
want a vaccine to kill the virus a job
to support your family
and freedom to live your life then go
cast your ballot you cast your ballot
we're changing we're changing things to
you could say what it used to be but
maybe it used to be a little bit like
this but it was never like this
things change i think with big tech i
think it really changed
joe biden personally ran the swine flu
right he ran
h1n1 remember he can't remember that he
always goes no
n1h1 isn't it no no
h comes before enjoy just remember it
that way
h1n1 flying flow remember he said uh the
what was that called who was that
governor from i think it was utah he's a
mormon what was his name
his name was romney all right he's he's
another beauty he failed horribly and he
was the laughingstock of washington
so he ran the swine flu operation he was
the laughing stock of
washington now on something much more
lethal that we have done a great job on
except with
public relations i would say if i had
nigel handling my public relations i
would have been much better
we have done a great job on this and you
compare us to
other places and you see in bringing
back the economy
opening it up except in public relations
but his own chief of staff said that he
was absolutely terrible
he didn't have a clue he didn't know
what he was doing
and he told us right that i was
xenophobic because i closed at
china which was highly and heavily
infected
and then he runs and he says i should
have closed it earlier
i said how does he get out of that one
you know how he gets out of that when
the press doesn't report it they refuse
to report
the only way i can do that is look i got
all live television all the likes
and the only way you know they can't
keep it off only for one reason i get
very big ratings
if i didn't get big ratings there'd be
no way of communicating
oh and they're going to miss those
ratings someday someday they're going to
miss
him secretary of defense robert gates
said that biden has been wrong
on nearly every single major foreign
policy and national security issue
over the past four years now he worked
with biden he worked with him
and he said he was wrong on like
everything and he is
and he he is but you don't have to take
my word for it
because this happens to be a statement
allow i spent a fortune on building
these
screens like you got two of them wow
usually i bring one it's a lot cheaper
roll the video please roll it
please
[Music]
from here
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
um
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
we cannot let this we've never
allowed any crisis from a civil war
[Music]
uh
all right
anyway i am uh i am very
willing to let the american public judge
my physical mental film
as well as my mental fitness i'll have
an effective strategy to mobilize
through an international depression
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't let that happen to our country by
the way that was just as small we could
we could keep you there all day watching
it now we can't let that happen to our
country we're
joined by some real warriors then
wow
[Music]
fred keller gt thompson
that's good with you with the three of
you what worries you've been
what worries you've been thank you very
much they were there at the beginning
and they have been with me all the way
and you have a couple of former members
that we love that we think are great
loop our letter and john marina
thank you very much tom thank you
thank you very much how are your
elections going by the way dan
[Music]
[Applause]
you got to vote for those guys
you're gonna do you have anything you're
thinking about look at them they look
healthy as can be
congressional congressional candidate
jim bognett thank you jim
thank you
and a woman who is doing an incredible
job
campaign chair bernie comfort bertie
thank you how's it going bernie
we're gonna have a big victory tomorrow
i think huh
we're gonna have a big a big one we
better bernie i'll fire you so
fast another great friend of mine a
great guy
david urban david
david thank you david and somebody that
i know very well he's a tall young
gentleman his name is eric
trump and he's done good
he's done
oh and i see jared kushner right over
here middle east peace
jared usually likes to stay in the plane
and work
he's working on middle east peace and
doing a great job you see what we're
doing decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding foreign
nations
fighting foreign wars defending our
border
but now we're finally protecting our
nation rebuilding our cities and we are
bringing our jobs
our factories and our troops back home
to the usa where they belong
for 47 years joe biden viciously
attacked
black americans he called young black
men
super predators all the time
to every black american
go tomorrow and vote for trump
this is your one and only chance to show
sleepy joe biden
what you think of his decision to attack
you jail you and betray you which is
what he did
i'm fighting for you and i got criminal
justice reform prison reform
opportunity zones with tim scott tim
scott the senator from south carolina is
great
and funding for historically black
colleges and
universities we got them the funding
long-term
funding and i say it all the time
i say it like this with the possible
exception of abraham lincoln a lot of
people like me to see
leave the word possible out there is no
president that has done more for the
black community
than donald trump it's true
[Applause]
and you're seeing that by the way you
see what's going on in florida
the numbers are very high like nobody's
seen before
with the black community and with the
hispanic american community
oh the hispanic american they're liking
trump i've done a lot for them and they
like me and i like that
i always have actually and they are
voting for us
very big they're coming out in florida
in numbers and the democrats are very
worried they say what's going
on what's going on you know what's going
on i've done a good job that's what's
going on
so i want to thank we have to see what
the final numbers are but i think i can
say in advance
african-american community
hispanic-american community
uh it's been incredible what's going on
in florida thank you very much
thank you very much you notice they're
not talking about florida too much right
they're not talking we get florida we
get pennsylvania
you watch under my leadership we achieve
the most secure border
in u.s history you know the wall the
wall is
over 400 miles long it'll be finished
soon
and they don't talk about that one
anymore either do they don't talk about
it
you know when you have success they
never talk about it
and jeremy you know what's happening you
know what's going on right
i mean other countries are coming in
they're studying what we're doing all
over the place they're studying
because what we've done nobody's been
able to do joe biden has pledged
open borders free health care for
illegal aliens
no not for you no see i delayed that a
little bit
no free health care for illegal aliens
they want to give them more than they
give us
and deadly sanctuary cities we believe
our cities
should be sanctuaries for law abiding
americans not for
criminal aliens the biden harris plan
would increase refugees from
terrorist nations by a staggering 700
percent
flooding into your towns and cities i am
keeping if it's okay with pennsylvania
i am keeping radical islamic terrorists
the hell out of our country you know i
passed the ban
early on and it uh ultimately got
approved by the united states supreme
court but i passed the ban because
we want people coming into our country
that can love us
and come in through merit and all sorts
of things
we don't want people coming into our
country that hate us
can't stand us and want to do harm to
our citizens okay
so the band was quite controversial but
it's had a big impact it's had a big
impact
and you know one of the reasons we're
going to win minnesota
ilhan omar ilhano
although she loves our country very much
she loves our country very much doesn't
she
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
united states military we have
the finest military the finest weaponry
in the world
all made in the usa with the envy of
russia and china and north korea
we have the best equipment in the world
rockets and missiles
and submarines and everything that we're
building nobody's ever seen anything
like it 2.5 trillion dollars
made in the usa we also passed
veterans we passed for our veterans va
choice after 44 years
and va accountability okay
va account that's where you say you're
fired get the hell out of here you're
not treating our vets right
we got i told you we got the highest
rating the highest approval rating
that has ever been given by our vets 91
approval who are the nine percent oh
they'll find somebody within the nine
percent to be on television
we obliterated 100 of the isis caliphate
we kill the leader of isis al-baghdadi
we eliminate the world's top terrorists
salamani is dead
i recognized the capital of israel and
opened the american embassy in jerusalem
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights 52 years
they worked on it for 52 years and
instead of endless war we are forging
peace in the middle east
good job he's doing it a vote for me
and the republican party is a vote for
the american dream
and who was a very distinguished person
within the republican party
the late great abraham lincoln please
remember
he was very presidential he's the only
one i said maybe i can't be that
presidential but
he was very presidential when he wore
the hat especially right
over the next four years we will make
america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all that's already
happening
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults or law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
you've got them you've got them with
god's help
we will defend the right to life
religious liberty
and the right to keep and bear arms
your second amendment your second
amendment
is gone if i don't get in if i don't get
in your second amendment wave combined
and i'll be sitting home and i'll be
saying i told the people of pennsylvania
you better
you better vote for trump now your
second amendment
is under siege
that's right we put amy on you happy
with amy everyone loves him
thank you you know we do they don't talk
about that enough they say it's the most
important thing a president can do
so at the end of my first term i will
have approximately
300 federal judges which is a big
percentage of the
judiciary and three great
supreme court justices that's a lot
many presidents have gotten to choose
none hey what ever happened to a pack in
the court you know
this guy's running he never gave an
answer maybe he's smarter than we think
whatever happened he never gave the
answer he never said he said he was
going to tell us
he never we're running you know people
are casting votes you cannot elect
somebody that's going to pack the court
and he's going to back the court
and he didn't give us a list of the
radical left judges he wants to put on
either
so he got away with it so he got away
with it he just did because the press
never pressed him right
see there's a case if that were me i
could never
ever get away he got away with it
because the fake news wouldn't press it
he never talked about packing the court
and we're voting right now
he shouldn't get a vote unless he tells
you because you will destroy this
country
that's a big thing packing the court can
you imagine
but they never picked it up we will
maintain america's unrivaled military
might
and we will ensure peace through
strength
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency lower drug prices you
know we're doing favored nations we're
gonna have the lowest prices anywhere in
the world
the drug companies hate me so much
they are spending more money on ads in
sleepy joe biden
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon in the united states will be the
first
nation to land an astronaut on mars
nasa nasa was like an abandoned place
and now it's the hottest
it's the hottest place in the world for
space
and that goes along with space force
doesn't it how we did space
we never even talked about space force
on the campaign
but we needed it when i saw russia when
i saw china we needed it we got it
approved
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and restore
patriotic education to our school
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great american
flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we try
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
pennsylvania i know you well
i know you well you're a rowdy bunch
today but that's okay
it's rowdy but it's rowdy with love
it's rowdy with love
tomorrow are you
nation that's what we're talking about
well you're going to be a large scale
version very large scale of venezuela
that's what happens it happens every
single time
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors get your co-workers
even grab your boss by the tie and say
come on boss
let's go we got to vote we got to vote
for generations america's destiny was
made
forged in one in places like bethlehem
and bristol
easton and allentown pittsburgh and
scranton right here in school
our american ancestors gave their blood
sweat and tears to defend our country
and to defend our freedom we stand on
the shoulders of american heroes
who crossed the ocean settled the
continent tamed the wilderness
laid down the railroads raised up the
great skyscrapers
won two world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and made america into the single
greatest nation
in the history of the world and the best
is yet
to come
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power to you
the american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of pennsylvania go out and vote tomorrow
we have made america powerful again our
military has never been
as even close to what it is right now
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you pennsylvania thank
you pennsylvania
[Music]
and
[Music]
are you listening
but you've got to know this
to the ymca i'm sure
[Music]
you can get to something
[Music]
i felt
why
there's no need
[Music]
[Music]
me
myself
[Music]
blue
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Music]
[Music]
dancing
always with me
tiny dancing in my
[Music]
we're gonna go on the street